pirates had infected the seas for
generations
so I vowed to eliminate them all Dutch
Boudreau crushed me I will have my
revenge issue LZ Jack Sparrow
first your pants a great planet does not
require such intricacies
Spyros arena is the only one who can
help us
looking for trouble was horrible lately
I'm a woman of science I choose not to
believe in ghosts do not see what's
behind us
monkey
I hope iris this stupid this film
contains scenes that may be too intense
for younger viewers pirates had him fit
the seas for generations
[Music]
so I'll eliminate them all
and then there was this boy
that's prob
follow him
he took everything from me
rate
[Applause]
the dead I've taken command of the sea
Musashi prepare
I've heard stories the mighty Spanish
captain my son to be killed thousands of
men no no no men go pirates pirates I
once knew Spaniard them something in
Spanish
he's coming future
personal [ __ ] the crew
your pants Jackie I'm so sorry we're
still talking the stores height
find Spyro for me
this woman told me ought to be our lives
chittering where your left hand as I
said we move man
[Music]
maybe
the trouble horrible way to leave
for what you did to me
men on that show are looking for jackets
I'm going to swim for it Kareena stop
that no no no no no that's not it this
has gone far enough
no it has not I saw her ankles you just
seen a lot more if you kept your
cakehole shot
you